after the Hamas Terror attacks on
October the 7th we have seen what is
nothing short of a disturbing outbreak
of virulent hatred anti-Semitism around
the world in the halls of our Congress
on American streets on college campuses
last month outside in Sydney uh Opera
House in Australia we've seen it all
over Europe but in Australia
anti-israeli protesters literally in
this day and age chanting gas the Jews F
the Jews m in American cities we have
protesters calling for Global Islamic
war and demanding that Israel be wiped
off the map or in the words of
congresswoman to leave from the river to
the Sea Israel meanwhile is vowing to
eradicate the terrorist group Hamas but
according to a report in the New York
Times this week us officials have warned
Israel that they need more uh to fight
more surgically in Gaza Governor Nome 30
seconds for you we have to cut back on
time all right how how can Israel win
the war against this terrorist group
using surgical strikes and directions
from from Joe bid I visited Isel I met
with families hostages I saw videos of
children being killed in front of their
parents parents being killed in front of
their children I saw a beheading with a
garden hoe this is not complicated to me
this is a fight between good and evil
Hamas is a terrorist organization and
they need to be eliminated not just for
the people of Israel and Jews around the
world but for the Palestinians
themselves but when it comes to the
issue of anti-Semitism you just
mentioned a lot of things that have been
occurring on Rond desantis's watch he
said nothing call an marching I'm saying
what H he countenanced anti-Semitism and
now he's finally talking a big game ever
since October 7th the
mass the you said nothing govern
issues than a second Holocaust they want
to destroy Israel and wipe every single
Jew uh off the map uh Israel has every
right to defend itself to the hilt Biden
should not be kneecapping them in any
way shape or form and by the way Biden
stranded a lot of American citizens over
there were trying to get home so I did
an executive order in Florida and we
sent planes over to Israel right in the
aftermath of October 7th and we saved
over 700 Americans mostly Floridians but
not all uh because Biden wouldn't do it
finally Biden started dumping people in
Greece and then they were sending a bill
to the Americans just to get to Greece
if you come to this country illegally
they will pay to fly you all over the
place they'll put you up in hotel at no
expense but yet our own citizens fleeing
a war zone they're going to send you a
bill Joe Biden failed those people and
we stepped up and got it let me ask you
I want want to anti-Semitism on your
streets for years want to turn to the
issue hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else